Katie psychedelia
[Music]
that is the way that you describe the
subliminal yet enchanting messages
embedded in our fairytale stories are
often full of psychedelic iconography by
way of I think the author reminding the
adults in the room that the truth that
sets you free is often one to be found
in altered states of consciousness think
of the fungi sprinkled everywhere in
Alice in Wonderland think of Peter Pan
as a child that never wants to grow up
the Lost Boys as those that concoct a
world shaped by their imagination now I
grew up loving these kid movies you know
Alice in Wonderland Willy Wonka
these were kiddie psyckadeli uh at it's
very best
Mary Poppins has that wonderful line
that says and feel the tension build in
the sense of wonderment spread as winds
in the East mist coming in like
something is blooming it's about to
begin
can't put my finger on what lies in
store but I think what's tab
has happened before I'm sorry where was
I
this is supposed to be a kids movie and
yet it's it's setting the stage for an
ontological awakening it's setting the
stage for a transformation it's setting
the stage for a character metamorphosis
you know we are in the birth canal and
the world is about to get
[Music]
ah Thank You mr. interesting and I think
we've had quite enough of this nonsense
please return to the nursery even Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory is laced
with psychedelic undertones perhaps no
better example exists than the boat ride
through the psychedelic tunnel as he
goes there's no earthly way of knowing
which direction they are going there's
no knowing where we're rowing which way
the rivers
we're there we're here
here we are on the precipice of
transformation we've eaten the mushroom
we feel the nausea the anxiety building
the roller-coaster climbs towards the
precipice
life itself in these moments we are
reminded by lines like space nothing to
hold on to and no one knows what's going
on good news is there is no these
stories Kitty psychedelia has the the
unta logical uncertainty totems embedded
therein whether it's the white rabbit
whether it's the magic mushrooms whether
it's falling down the rabbit hole
whether it's falling through the
looking-glass whether it's entering the
liminal space of the chocolate pour
those into archetypal spaces of mind and
meaning the true spaces in which we live
right the domain of dream the domain of
the myth so poetic the domain of
storytelling and mythology writes the
truthful fictions in which we find what
we are looking for and my god I think
today with so many people seemingly lost
and the reservation of any kind of
tethering that allows them to function
with equanimity in the world we can all
turn back towards these old tales these
staring tales fairy tales and
mythologies and full chloric stories
these these Kitty psyckadeli these
narratives like dr. Seuss's oh the
places we'll go to to remind us of what
life is all about to remind us of the
patterns of meaning that we can that we
can use to to center ourselves and in
dentate ourselves and find our North
Star and find the pot of gold and
the you know the the cave we fear that
holds the treasure we seek I wish that
for you I wish that for me I wish that
for all of us